[Musique]
avec vos laines Frade bonjour Hélène
bonjour Pauline à la une de la presse
française l'annonce hier de la mise en
cause de 11 évêques ou anciens évêques
devant la justice civile ou la justice
de l'église pour de nouvelles affaires
de violences sexuelles la réunion à
lourde depuis la semaine dernière la
Conférence des évêques de France
cherchent à établir plus de transparence
sur les affaires de violence sexuelles
au sein de l'Église et c'est donc dans
ce cadre qui ont été exposés ces 11
clercs mis en cause une douloureuse
vérité pour le journal Lacroix qui
exprime sa sidération face à la crise
sans fin traversée par l'Église de
France un an après le rapport accablant
de la commission indépendante sur les
abus sexuels au sein de l'Église qu'on
ne vienne plus remettre en cause le
caractère systémique des abus nous en
avons la démonstration sous les yeux
regrette le journal chrétien qui se
demande s'il sera possible un jour
d'éprouver par-delà le sentiment de
trahison une forme de reconnaissance
pour ceux qui au sein de l’épique de
l'épiscopat français accomplissent ce
pénible travail de lucidité Le Figaro
indique que parmi les mises en cause se
trouve le cardinal Jean-Pierre Ricard
une figure du catholicisme français qui
a notamment participé à l'élection du
pape François en 2013 et qui a reconnu
je le cite cette conduite de façon
répréhensible avec une jeune fille de 14
ans il y a 35 ans alors qu'il était
prêtre dans le diocèse de Marseille
voilà pour cette affaire direction à
présent les États-Unis les électeurs ont
voté dans quelques heures aux élections
de mi-mandat des électeurs que le
nouveau patron de Twitter Elon Musk qui
a appelé à voter en faveur des
républicains politico le milliardaire
américain a justifié ce choix par la
nécessité d'équilibrer les pouvoirs le
partage du pouvoir limite les pires
excès donc je recommande de voter pour
un congrès républicain étant donné que
la présidence
déclaré le patron de Twitter sur son
propre réseau social après avoir promis
que celui-ci demeurait politiquement
neutre ces propos laissent le
Frankforter alguemines
passablement dubitatif Elon Musk East
eineliste Elon Musk est un feu follet
écrit le journal photo du patron de
Tesla en tenue de gladiateur en
compagnie de sa mère déguisée en Cruella
à l'appui le quotidien allemand
soupçonne et le musk de ne pas avoir de
modèle économiques pour Twitter mais
d'avoir peut-être en revanche un projet
politique et il fustige en tout cas son
discours sur la soi-disant nécessité de
partager le pouvoir entre les démocrates
et les partisans d'un candidat Donald
Trump et qui a tenté un coup d'État en
prenant des saules Capitole tout cela
n'a rien à voir avec la séparation des
pouvoirs et les règles démocratiques la
scène le journal dites à tendre de voir
si Elon Musk se mettra au service de
Donald Trump avec Twitter
votre sortie Hélène remarqué sur
toujours c'est mi termes américaine la
déclaration hier devganis Prigogine le
dirigeant du groupe paramilitaire Wagner
proche on le sait de Moscou et l'homme
d'affaires a ami des ingérences dans les
élections passées et il a enfoncé le
clou en compte en assurant qu'il
continue à être à le faire des propos
sans surprise selon de Guardian qui
explique que cette provocation a surtout
pour but en réalité de créer la méfiance
vis-à-vis de la santé des institutions
démocratiques en disant qu'il continue
d'interférer dans les élections
américaines privées
que les résultats ne sont pas fiables
les discours qui a infusé on le sait au
sein d'une bonne partie du camp
conservateur d'une provocation à l'autre
en Pologne le patron du pitch le parti
au pouvoir a provoqué les mois c'était
le week-end dernier après avoir accusé
les femmes je cite d'être responsables
du faible taux de natalité dans le pays
avec des explications ma foi
que je vais vous laisser nous nous faire
rêver Hélène le Franck toujours un
rapport que hier au Slav kassinsky était
interrogé sur le plongeon de la natalité
en Pologne quand il a répondu je le cite
que c'est rien ne change c'est-à-dire si
jusqu'à l'âge de 25 ans une jeune fille
boit autant que tu es contemporain alors
elle ne frappe pas dansant
sous-entendant ainsi que le goût des
Polonaises pour l'alcool serait la cause
du problème mais se payant même le luxe
Pauline d'ajouter qu'un homme a besoin
de deux décennies pour tomber dans
l'alcoolisme alors qu'une femme n'aurait
besoin que de deux ans ces propos de
comptoirs ont été aussitôt dénoncés par
l'opposition polonaise et c'est ce que
rapporte gaz état lit bolcha et qui cite
notamment une députée de la coalition
citoyenne estimant que kassinski
insultait toutes les femmes en déclarant
qu'elle ne mettait pas d'enfants au
monde parce qu'elle picole le quotidien
polonais
en quête d'opinion à l'appui j'en perds
mon latin avant celui d'autres
explications le fait que les Polonaises
et les Polonais estiment à 59% que ce
faible taux de natalité est dû au manque
de stabilité financière et l'incertitude
quand elle est venue à la situation
défavorable du marché du logement 44% ou
encore à l'insuffisance des aides de
l'État 23%
. on ne se quitte pas là-dessus Hélène
avant de vous dire à tout à l'heure
Pauline je vous propose de jeter un cil
au Times le quotidien britannique alors
je n'ai pas l'image à vous mais vous
pouvez quand même
oui il fait état d'une étude ma foi
passionnante sur la vie en société des
cochons des chercheurs en société des
chercheurs italiens pardon ont en effet
démontré que ces bestioles ont des
stratégies de résolution des conflits
extrêmement sophistiqués comme par
exemple lorsqu'une querelle éclate entre
deux pores et bien un troisième cochon
vient aplanir les difficultés arrondir
les angles une fois qu'elle met la
victime et l'agresseurs paraît-il se
réconcilier en se frottant le nez et en
se couchant ensuite l'un à côté de
l'autre d'où l'expression sans doute
Pauline copain comme cochon mais oui
bien sûr avoir un bon copain aussi comme
on dit merci beaucoup Hélène c'était
larve vite presse